battle the doctor set my parents down
and said my life was fragile perspective
is the game i guarantee the name just
put your head down do the work and
everything will change
sympathy helping fields yeah that's what
i wanted be a patient hello
[Music]
july 22nd 2020
super fired up big shout out to my brave
change robert cloudy in the building
lucia chef what's good kelly
hill in the building love tribe big
shout out to
youtube facebook periscope i see you all
twitch
squad in the building where's the
linkedin family
let's see a linkedin logo leave your
comment leave your comment
good to see you bro i've really did i
hope as
much as i have hovid uh
i'm really excited for this today abel
franco what's good
my man it's been really fun having you
part of this if you've
been following every episode abel good
uh really good friend of mine from
grammar middle school we relived some
wrestling memories too so
that was fun really really good to see
all of you now
the big question is who's part of the
share squad who's part of the share
squad who right now
is going to copy the url
hit the share link in their ecosystem
whether it's twitch linkedin
twitter facebook who is going to take
that url
and paste it into a facebook post or a
linkedin post or twitter post or just
hit the little share button
let's get some new homies in here if you
have
shared the url right now to your
audience on social
please leave hashtag share squad let me
see who else is in here vicky good to
see you always
luke says hey guys that means he's from
australia
orlando mckenzie i appreciate you on
linkedin
somebody just hit shared i want to give
shout outs to shared house of social
uh let's see what's going on what's
gucci everything's gucci bassy boom
what's good hannah lee you're amazing
thank you for the love big fort
lauderdale
what's up chat share share share share
share share share share share
amanda smith is part of the share squad
new england property disposal
is part of the shooter squad dustin how
are you
great buying some pokemon
yeah i got two on the way all right
let's share that
uh i uh everything's getting sold out
i think uh i bought a red shakes e3
giveaway promo 1999 ps810
last night how much maybe 625 i think i
got it for
interesting it was a promo card from
ebay
on ebay promo card first year e3 pikachu
yep you missed it i grabbed it
i'm also going completely ham on vintage
basketball
like just dr j akeem magic bird
barkley drexler ewing stockton
elgin baylor barry west going hammy ham
ham
i know basketball
like i'm a ham sandwich
all right let's get into the show
garyvee what's up my man what's good jc
how are you
hey i'm really good bro this is an
absolute pleasure brother
thank you where are you from i'm from
perth australia my man
yeah the west coast of australia man it
is
it's beautiful there yeah man it's crazy
to actually uh
be talking to you right now man this has
been a big manifestation
like three five years in the making
before we get into it man i want to
shout out my manager julian
he he hustled this he made it what
happen just talking to andy k
and um zane for some prime so big shout
out to julian and nick obviously
of course yeah my man uh
i just i just what so i just started off
man and i just tell you a little bit
yeah give me some context and give me
the question yeah so my name is
jc i'm an artist an independent artist
uh representing australia
i'm true to my music i'm passionate
about my music
um and yeah last some examples of what
i've done last year i put out 26
music videos every single week every
song produced mixed mastered by myself
um dropped that every week and that was
a guinness book world record
i also um every yeah like follow
following the ross blueprint i've
dropped songs every week i've been on
tick tock man i've got
a following on tick tock thanks to you
you got me onto that when the time was
right
um i've got and now i'm in this position
now where i've got fans
building i've got you know half a
million tick top followers
i've got you know 20 000 spotify
listeners i've got labels now hitting me
up big major labels hitting me up and
i've got
my songs on commercial radio and i'm
just like me and the team were thinking
what's the next move
um where do we go from here in this i
think
the next i think the next move is to
build out a distribution network that
isn't
just social media what i mean by that is
if i'm an artist and i've got everything
that i just heard you talking about
the thing i'm thinking about is how do i
make sure that more people hear it
the next time i put something out and
the way to do that is of course things
like tick tock or youtube or instagram
but the other way to do that is to
actually spend 500 hours as a team
reaching out to every music blogger
every music
you know uh communicator like mike boyd
on my team
who puts who uh puts playlists together
reach out to a thousand playlists
spotify playlist curators
reach out to a thousand music bloggers
reach out to a thousand instagram music
accounts that
share new stuff create one-to-one
relationships
with distribution reach out to 5 000
youtube influencers and say yo
i would love to make you some original
music um
please yeah right yeah and that that
and that's funny that you say that
because that's what we have essentially
been doing
i don't know to the extreme of a
thousand or whatever it takes
it takes the extreme because when you
have a new song if you got 34 people
only three are actually going to put it
all out because they got a bunch of
other [ __ ] going on they want to write
about something else they want to
do something else so i actually do think
it's to the extreme my big thing is
if you want to live your dream yeah this
is for everybody who's watching right
now if you want to live your dream
how the [ __ ] are you not going to the
extreme and i mean it it's like
you know it's kind of like working out
right like i'm blown away
yesterday mike my trainer i work out
virtually with him every day
and he had me doing this goblet squat
and it was like 52.5 like max weight on
the bowflex thing that i had to order
but the amount of reps he asked me doing
he had me do one and a halfs
and i and i just remember thinking i was
like i can't do this
and i did it and i was like right like
if i want to get healthier if i want to
build muscle
if i want to build my core and my legs
so when i'm 85
i don't trip and that starts the path to
death well of course i've got to push
myself to extreme
if you're an artist if you're somebody
who's trying to make it
become famous become an influencer make
a million dollars all these crazy things
that come out of people's mouths
i actually think jc like i'm excited
we're together it's like no no it's a
thousand
i i i completely agree with you gary i
am i am
all about that so it's the same way you
know i watched
every single wrestling interview i've
watched oh you're um gary vee
um you must have loved when russ was on
my podcast that must have been one of
your favorites
that's what did it i saw that and i saw
this song a week i'm a huge rust fan
i produced all this stuff and that's
what did it we had the same conversation
and i was like i want to do a song a
week as well
and that's what did it and it was a big
learning curve man because it goes to
it really tests you and it really goes
back to what are your intentions behind
doing it
you know for me i did the song a week
and my results weren't like
one blew up one did this it was it
really humbled me and it made me realize
that you know it's really about the
music and it's really about
the love and the passion and what's your
intention what are you trying to bring
to the world
jason i really i really really really
really believe
that the number one human thing that you
and team have to figure out
is more distribution okay period
right like like i honestly you wanna do
everybody's watching wanna do something
interesting go type in my name
on youtube and search least views
right go watch how much [ __ ] i've done
for how long this is actually like this
is really relevant because i was like we
actually had a discussion last night
because we're
we're in the middle between putting we
don't know whether to put it all out
and then have it our flaws out there and
our perfections out there
oh yes that that
don't even debate no more imperfections
out imperfections out
other thing i would look very heavily
into video game culture
i would hit up a ton of twitch streamers
try to win that esports video game
culture that's a real spot
right right um okay sweet also gary i
want to say thank you for the following
tick tock
my guy i don't know if that was you who
did that that was me
oh so you're watching are you watching
i'm the only one i'm the only one who
controls who i follow i'm the only one
i'm the only one
there's a reason there's a teamgaryvee
account so that
they can do those things i everything
that's garyvee i write
i follow i live it's me all right jason
i'm going to run because i got a bunch
of people coming on
love you man you push it follow gc
everyone take care
move it
let's keep this moving what's
up well friends what's up old friend
tomorrow so listen
everybody i was going to do a podcast
this week and bring together and notice
that tomorrow said
old friend we've known each other from
day one twitter
we're talking o.g life when there was
like me and her and like
5 000 people on twitter early twitter
uh and we were catching up she's doing
something incredible that i've been
like really passionate about that she's
up to and we were just catching up
on zoom last week and it's tomorrow you
know what i'm gonna do a podcast and get
four or five old friends together and do
an old friend show
unfortunately i just got a little
sidetracked with my business so last
night
big shout out to tamar to always staying
persistent because i'm busy i'm chaotic
my intent is there
but i'm getting hit by baseball's left
and right she
hits up yesterday like hey my my
fundraising for my
uh and i'll let her explain it and i was
like [ __ ] cool let's get you on with tea
with garyvee so
tomorrow do me a favor a tell everybody
what you're up to because i want
everybody supporting it doesn't pay
attention to the url or
or this is probably good because she can
share it all on on on
twitter after but i think a lot of you
are going to be blown up yeah that's too
long of an iphone me so let's put her
twitter handle
and tomorrow after you're done here put
the links up if you
if you love me in any way this is a real
og friend of mine
please go contribute a little bit to our
project wait to hear what it is tomorrow
tell them what it is
yeah yeah thank you so much all right so
um i
first of all yeah i've known garyvee
since the early early tech days i was
working in second marketing for
over a decade and uh didn't realize when
gary basically had his first kid i had
my own first kid and
i had a postpartum depression for it
lasted for nine years
i hit a rock bottom in 2018 i was not in
a good place woke up
went through the motions that was my
life um
one day i i found a little vial of
perfume
in a cabinet and when you're depressed
you don't care what you look like i
certainly didn't you definitely don't
care what you smell like
and the thing is most people put on
perfume with no objective but to like
smell good for other people but
that obviously wasn't me i didn't give i
didn't care about myself at all
and that was life-changing for me i
don't really know exactly what it was
but it was an impetus to start living my
life
again and i decided i was going to do
something
in this perfume world i started studying
scents reading books
consuming all the media possible joining
all the communities wherever i could
possibly be
and i thought you know what i'm gonna
start a brand called tamar
tomorrow.com and with the objective of
making perfume uh have basically
happiness in a bottle
and i was crazy but i launched uh did a
soft launch in may
and i'm still in the middle of this
fundraising right now because
right now is the right time i'm thinking
about i mean it's the worst time
financially but at the same time we
don't feel good for ourselves right now
we're stuck at home
we don't love ourselves and this little
thing that you could do
and revisit this sniffing your wrist
throughout the day it can
actually change you and make you feel
better so that's my story
and i'm in the middle fundraising for
this everybody
when i think about self-esteem it is the
only thing i kind of almost care about
because it leads to happiness which then
leads to
kindness for others when tomorrow was
telling me
scent drove this reality for her it just
really hit me like a ton of bricks and
it was about doing it for you
instead of doing it for someone else hit
me like a ton of bricks so it's a dear
friend
please please please go to tamar.com but
also
tomorrow do me a favor because i know
you're at tomorrow on twitter please put
up links to your
your funding page right now i would love
the vaynernation to give a little love
i've done my part please do a little bit
of your part i love you
keep pushing this story i think there's
something tomorrow i really believe
you'll be historically correct about
this because after you told me
i did some homework it's [ __ ]
fascinating
yeah yeah thank you um so if you go to
tomorrow.com there's actually a link
that you want to learn about the
campaign
that's live ends on 7 31 so that's next
friday
so your support is definitely
appreciated thank you so much gary i
really really appreciate it and
everybody
go hit up tomorrow right now with
further questions or highs and hellos
like everybody go to your twitter right
now and just say what's up tamar
especially if you're interested in this
project so that she can engage with you
on twitter for the rest of the day
awesome love you talk to you soon love
you too take care
i want to do dustin i want to do more of
that i want to i want to do a little bit
more of like sneaking in like one person
just giving love during
tea with garyvee what do you think yeah
just nice right
yeah yeah but i wanted to be authentic
to me not
the team for like that he needs to
remind me to like what inspired you
today or who do you want to help today
instead of like
we picked this person because i don't
want to be zayn's [ __ ] thing that
inspired zayn
i think we have a good understanding of
that
it's for you not for us no no i want to
pick it
all right just let us know
let's keep moving
dustin what's good what's going on man
life is good you
oh it's going great good uh first off
i've got to say
i mean thank you so much for for
everything you've done i i started my
youtube channel
about a hundred days ago uh mainly
focused around collectibles investing
sports card investing
slash collecting um we get in all things
action figures and video games and all
that stuff i think it's all cool
by the way the the two categories action
figures and video games
that i collected in between and flipped
in between my 1993 and my
two years ago sports cards me and aj's
garage sailing was
80 toys and video games
aj and i were so right about video games
we were buying nintendo cartridges for
a quarter at garage sales and yard sales
a piece maybe a dollar but only if it
was contra mike tyson's punch out and
zelda and mario's
in like in like 2000
2003 to 2003
action we crushed wrestling figures we
crushed i mean
at that point even in 2003 it was hard
to find transformers gi joe's star wars
but we would but i i probably am
as knowledgeable about action figure i
mean i know more about
migo star like superhero stuff like like
you know i mean the amount i know about
ljns and and
and hasbro wrestling figures uh i know
thundercats and like
i know that space extremely well oh the
best yeah
the thundercats figures they're where i
know i know video game i know atari 2600
like crazy climber was a mail away
cartridge like i know
paper mario like like i know my [ __ ]
yeah
i'm sneaky i'm sneakier about knowledge
that people realize
well part of my channel is kind of going
back to my childhood and the nostalgia
and it's maybe it's part of the midlife
crisis
and i'm approaching it's
happiness it really is yeah like unlike
crisis is like doing selfish [ __ ]
they're like [ __ ] like no no this is
happiness
that's what i call my wife like sports
cards thing is [ __ ] crazy i just got
a mail package why don't you tell
everybody about you i'm gonna go to my
package and share with you while because
i don't get to share what i like because
now i'm almost here to like post [ __ ]
because like
the price goes up and everybody gets mad
but in this environment i'm gonna just
share what i just got but why don't you
tell everybody a little about that and
then i want to hear your question
yeah so um i started out about a hundred
days ago
i've created 160 plus
videos on youtube on my channel the
personal finance dad
um and it's it's all around kind of
getting back into the hobby
i was i got back in about two years ago
after about a 25 year hiatus i started
collecting in the late 80s early 90s
like a lot of a lot of my peers that can
relate
and so just kind of getting back into it
going back to my childhood
um started creating content really
having fun with it and then it kind of
you know sagged into other things like
video games and comic books
and um you know we just kind of kind of
gone from there but
um but yeah no it's it's been a great
time and it's a great community it's
amazing how many people are
are getting back into it or just people
that are new getting into it
it's it's wild so um
not sure you know what more else to say
but actually
i and gary's talking about a male day
you know thing i actually got a package
i got a letter from
a kid a 12 year old that sold me
something on ebay that said hey
it was a handwritten note from a 12 year
old you know that said
thank you very much for your purchase we
appreciate it it reminded me of when i
was 10 years old except i didn't have
ebay and didn't have all these options
to buy singles online
so it was just it was refreshing so it
just shows you kind of all generations
the the hobbies exploding and the
happiness is absurd dustin get in here
let's tell like dustin dustin like
dustin how much happiness has getting
into collecting pokemon and flipping
pokemon been for you
it's been surprisingly fun like i
thought it would be stupid at first but
now i'm kind of like really like
yeah because i feel like i guess i'm
learning a skill in a way like
oh yeah yeah yeah there's a lot of
business and negotiation behind it i
mean i was saying too and like
yeah go ahead when i was eight years old
i was battling with you know
local card shop owners trying to
negotiate out that was my first foray
into business negotiation
i was trying to buy cards at the local
lcs oh are you kidding me like like
of course i'm like when people are like
you're like you're a savant i'm like no
i'm well trained i've been doing this
every day
like it's no it's a huge huge thing
and it's listen there's nothing more fun
than to have a ton of fun and
it make you money versus it cost you
money
yeah most things that are super [ __ ]
fun
cost money yeah spending two hours
searching on ebay when you know
what's going on and like trying to find
that diamond in the rough
and you have fun with it you're gonna
make money doing that
versus watching something on hulu that
you paid a subscription for to be
entertained you're being entertained to
learn
and to have fun and
most of all it makes money right listen
there are
tens of millions of people out of a job
we are completely being disguised by
kovit our government is just printing
money
to throw out the problem like the
economy is going to get punched in the
face
like understanding how to make money
right now i've had
over 25 people literally you know 25 is
a big number with what i'm about to say
because i've been counting it
say that through dm and email that
card flipping has fundamentally allowed
their family to not be in a shitty
situation during this time and had they
not heard me
in october november january last year do
it like they would be they lost their
job
and like they were paying their rent and
eating like like
emotional [ __ ] yeah yeah
on the record for everybody's watching
markets go down
and also there's some level of gambling
let me give an example one of the things
i'm most interested in gambling
so football is coming up obviously i
love watching this but when the viking
when the
panthers are playing the packers i don't
give a [ __ ] and i don't gamble
but now this year when the panthers play
the packers i'm going to care because i
have this weird feeling that
teddy bridgewater is going to have a
good year and he's the starting
quarterback in carolina
and this is like fun for me now because
like buying these and if he has a good
year
boom or or then there's like other stuff
so like this one
like this just means a lot to me willis
reed is one of the greatest knicks of
all time
this is a almost perfect card sgc 9.5
from a 1969 set think about how old that
is
yeah it's i'm one of the great knicks
right so like that's fun
i bought this this was super interesting
to me these messy stickers were
super cheap six months ago yeah
and he's obviously and i think soccer
cards are just and stickers are gonna be
some of the most expensive stuff
and they were like one of the most
important things there's a weird little
set it wasn't like the big one
but these have gone from like 80 to like
600 bucks
in like a couple months i was right
because it's messy it's o4 and psa 10
right
and then my favorite thing old
basketball these aren't even in great
shape
these are literally from a hot dog
company
literally literally from cons the wiener
that the world
look at this thing cons of wieners
dustin that's funny to you you like
weiner you're like an adolescent
and then obviously like these are two of
the most iconic players of all time
oscar robertson literally jerry west is
the logo on the [ __ ] jersey
yeah uh you know so like that's that's
why it's fun that was my little stash
that came in
that's awesome man that is awesome
yeah the first question i wanted to ask
you so a lot of folks have
and this has caught the mainstream
attention we've seen this but recently a
lebron
rpa sold 400 1.8 million dollars
i guess my question is just from your
you know your opinion on it
do you see more or any i i don't have
any insight
institutional money coming in this was
something that happened 15 20 years ago
with coins with warehouses
and you saw i mean you know pricing just
went through the roof
well tell me about that educate me
dustin because the answer is yes
i believe that there's a
stunning amount of real money
institutional money coming in
um i know of people that have been
approached that are on wall street
by others i've i've heard of
conversations i've been asked
for my information of what i see what i
know
yes do i believe like do i believe a
hundred million dollars
of five to fifteen to thirty groups
comes into the sports card world
and starts buying up super premium stuff
because this is this generation's art
yes i do do i think
that a 52 year old high net worth
individual from new york
that wants to remember or maybe 60 year
old that wants us to remember
that knicks championship because we've
sucked for so long that
this one of the only perfectly graded
willis reed cards
is actually worth 20 times what it's
worth right now the second
new york money comes in yes i believe
that right
yeah you know and and that's not me
promote like
i get so frustrated when people like
gary vee like i'm yes i have an audience
and i'm sure i've brought in a lot of
awareness but this was so first of all
the only reason i've loved cards since i
was eight
i've been i've had notoriety and
awareness for a decade
i didn't talk about cards because it
wasn't happening right i'm talking about
it because it's happening but the answer
is yes
i do believe that's happening now my
question to you is i've not educated
myself
on i know that the coin market's a much
bigger market than the card market which
makes no sense because nobody under 50
gives a [ __ ] about coins and everybody
and a
shocking amount under 50 care about
cards but i'm not educated on what
happened to that scarcity i'm more
educated what happened with art
in the turn of the century educate me a
little bit what do you know about the
coin and it's very my my knowledge is
very basic that was just something that
as i was doing research i saw i saw
i saw a graph of it where literally
institutional money got into rare coins
and it shot through the absolute roof
and then within kind of a two year
period it it started to you know it
does it did come down but it did create
kind of a new floor
you know for for you know rare coins
so it and that's the thing if the answer
is yes i want to move on
to other subjects but the answer is
absolutely yes i i think that this is
early the economy could collapse and
people may not look for alternative
investments that can change things
markets go up and down there's you know
teddy bridgewater could get benched into
week two and like that's why i don't
really buy new stuff this is more to
entertain me but but this stuff this
stuff
and the global icons that have already
made it right
absolutely no-brainers to me next
question um
what what types of innovations would you
like to see that could advance the hobby
you know that there's only one big one
the machines that come along that grade
cards instead of humans
yeah when ai technology when that comes
it's going to go through the roof but by
the way but
humans judge antiques and art now
yeah so like let's not let's not you
know forget that
so anyway i got to move on that's a
lovely pillow we'll talk soon
thanks very much it'll be a card only
show we'll make sure we get you back on
i love it thanks gary
when you say how dare you card grading
is an art i'm a big fan i just think
that technology will help it because a
lot of people are concerned
about the human aspects of grading where
people
manipulate and things of that nature and
you know that's always a tension
like it is in any other human-based
subjective world and
so i do think that technology will come
and that's not that's not my opinion
that's just knowing the advancements of
technology that
will eventually get there let's keep
moving
hi gary good morning hey andrea how are
you how are you thank you for your time
thank you for we're doing tea with
garyvee you're welcome real quick
everybody's watching share squad time
it's share squad time andre do this with
me share share share
share share share share share share
share share everybody share if you're
watching go ahead what's your question
okay so a quick story um quick
background i work in the live
and event industry so in february of
this year i decided uh start doing my
own shows
i'll go on my own producing my own
projects keep thriving
um in january of this year i became
pregnant um
thank you um so then however
march came covet came and then of course
i mean the majority of the events that i
had confirmed or whether they were
rescheduled or were cancelled yeah trust
me i know
most of my money comes from speaking all
gone to zero so it's been an intense
time
so and also the uncertainty as well so
um
but however um i mean i've been working
on new things and then
one of the things that i've been working
is woodworking okay well
basically uh by the way i've never
worked with uh
wood before like carved anything so i
started carving out uh
kitchen utensils out of wood um all of a
sudden
and then i really enjoyed it um i do see
a big
vision in it um like in the near future
but however i'm still learning
in order for me to sell it out to the
public and then provide this
product up in the near future so that's
one thing
i mean this is one of the spatulas that
i've done so cool
good for you i'm really proud of you i
think a lot of people
during cobit exposed a lot of things
where a lot of people
had something bad happen like live
events or restaurants
they fell into a huddle and cried and
other people
just attacked something else and
innovated i'm just really impressed by
your will
and your creativity thank you um yeah i
mean it's been
a roller coaster i mean it's just
dealing with so many
emotions and also the pregnancy and
everything so of course
um but however additionally um i
work with a production company called
mestizo productions
um before all covered i mean this is um
we work a live
entertainment production company uh
making auto visual performances
for uh live i mean social events
corporate
so on um and uh i mean we build uh
entertainment
for process of brands product
promotional products and so on and so
forth
so um with this is through live talent
jobs uh percussion musicians
and however we've been pivoting and make
taking these elements and then uh
providing the service to virtual events
the virtual events that are happening
right now making it more
um engaging more interactive you're
becoming a production company
in the reality of a digital virtual
world instead of a physical one
exactly so however i mean we're still
trying to learn how can we do all these
performances like with the musicians
with the dancers
with uh the recording because it's
pre-recorded um
and then yes so basically just providing
the service to all the clients that we
have
or new and clients and basically just
making it more of
a solution or making it more interactive
with the audience like something
because you're sitting down and on the
computer and then just with the
conference and make it more interactive
um so my question to you is my
whole question um how would
seeing all this how would you manage um
whether it's the woodworking the
pivoting in
well i got a lot of events i have a huge
answer for you
the number one thing that you need to
think about is not over
judging yourself on a daily weekly or
monthly basis
yes i loved
every single thing that came out of your
mouth thank you so much you are trying
you're ambitious
you're thoughtful the number one
vulnerability you have
is over judging yourself yeah
yeah it has been and also i mean it's
also like all the struggling also
because of
the pregnancy and then you have to feel
good and then in order for you to
because you're carrying a living person
inside of you so
i've heard but anyhow i mean that's
that's uh please listen to this it's the
number one part
yes you everything i've heard is
phenomenal it's going to be great
and the only thing that you have to do
is say don't allow yourself to say
i should have done more or [ __ ] i should
have i sh
the words i should have are literally
the worst combo of words that i can
think of for most people
because it leads to deep anxiety it
leads to
anxiousness it leads to sadness which
then leads
which then leads to people not being
nice to other people you know who's not
nice
people that are hurting and
do you know do you know how one gets
hurt they over
judge themselves they decide they're a
bad person without realizing they're
actually a hurt person
and and are wonderful but just hurt they
decide that the world is
unfair because they they weren't
lucky enough to have work ethic and they
just are entitled and think everything
should come to them
you are [ __ ] killing it with your
energy
i want you to first be you should
like my hope for you without knowing you
is for you to enjoy this pregnancy
i think it's so special it's so special
i want you to know that everything's
gonna be okay when you have this kind of
energy
and this kind of ambition and this kind
of creativity it's all gonna be okay
i want you to know you have time i i
left my family business at 34 years old
with nothing
no i didn't have any net worth i like i
started vaynermedia in the conference
room of another company
because i had no money to pay for rent
i didn't judge myself like oh that was
stupid to build that business for my
family it was
it made me proud i was 34.
wow i was 34 years old
i had saved a lot of money in my 20s but
i just put that into facebook and
twitter because i thought it was going
to work and guess what it did
and so i didn't have money i was 34.
wow i was 34 and couldn't
and had no business had no vaynermedia
had no notoriety had no speaking career
had not written a book
got no had made zero dollars in speaking
and i was thumped because i knew i had
talent
i knew that i had ambition
and i knew i had time i want to see lee
jay plummer in the comments right now
say i feel good at that this makes me
good at 35 how old are you
me uh 32 you have unlimited time
yes 32 33 34 41 i'm 44 right now and i
[ __ ] when i tell you i feel so young
i don't think i've i don't think i've
even started
as everything that's happening i don't
think you know the distance between
where i'm at now to get to this
ownership is very far and i'm not
crippled by it
because i'm just starting yeah
people in the comments right now that
are 27 29 29
is [ __ ] up age because everyone's like
oh 30 and it's over society
society has made a huge mistake in the
way that we've
taught people about age
i mean i'm interacting with 63 year olds
that are just
realizing that they're leaving corporate
america and starting their own business
and they've never been more alive and
they're 63
and healthy and vibrant and acting like
they're 42 from a generation earlier
because we're all younger
we're eating better we're taking care of
ourselves more
the only mistake you can make is beating
yourself up you've got everything
should you do more woodwork maybe should
you should you learn more about
virtualbox maybe
do i think virtual events are going to
be huge forever yes i do and i think you
should double down on that
but the number one thing you need to do
is enjoy this pregnancy
because it's extremely special and
woodwork and production
and business and [ __ ] money it will
all be there okay
enjoy it don't beat yourself up it's not
the time to be stressed
yeah i mean it's of course it's been
[Music]
um it's been a roller coaster it's
always
it could also listen everyone's like
it's a roller coaster that's so intense
cool let's all
role play in two years from now cove
it's all set we're back to
normal and then your best friend
dies of cancer and then and then
your government has election and goes to
fascism and then your
your partner dies of a heart attack and
then your child gets diagnosed with
a disease life is always yeah
yep do you know that if covid started
three months earlier kobe bryant would
be alive
yeah life was super fine in january
in america if kovitz started in december
kobe wouldn't be in that helicopter he'd
be alive for another 60 years
life is unpredictable
it is so you know how many people's
lives were saved by covet because their
destiny was to be on a highway and get
into an accident that night but they
were stuck at home
complaining that they're bored
wow yeah people don't people don't
understand life
yeah we need a better perspective you
are so lucky you're lucky you know many
women right now are crying every day in
their sleep because they can't get
pregnant
yes i mean i've thought of that about
that every day i mean
i believe you i'm not saying you don't
i'm talking to the audience right now
like be grateful for what you have
be grateful for what you have instead of
stressed about what isn't going well
every day i have thousands of things
hundreds of things
tens of things not going well i run a
huge company
there's unlimited things going on i have
a big personality there's always
hate being thrown out like i can't dwell
on that i have to be too grateful for
the health of the people i love the
end gratitude is the formula
it is so the oh so one long-winded
answer for
the right answer for you is don't beat
yourself up you are clearly
clearly a fortunate person with the
right ingredients to
figure it out thank you so much enjoy
this
figure out how to enjoy this enjoy you
know there's so many kids complaining
that they're at home with their parents
and this is the last chapter that
they're ever going to have meaningfully
with their parents before their parents
die
and they're not enjoying it they're
complaining about it
and in three years they're gonna cry
like a baby looking back to the six
months they were at their parents house
during covid
and wish they played more board games i
wish they did come downstairs
and watch tv with their mom like people
take [ __ ] for granted out here
yeah um yeah and things like this i mean
you know it's
whether i mean sometimes i just think
about the future but then sometimes i am
like grateful like oh my god thank you
so much it's giving me more time to just
sit down and
just be with my baby and then just get
the pregnancy by the way i respect the
[ __ ] out of you i do the same i love
that you have a thought to the future
you have to strategize
it's good but it can't [ __ ] you and
most of all
you have to recognize you're just a
human being you're doing the best you
can
yes awesome that's it thank you
let's keep it going it sure is cat heart
garyvee what's good sean what's good bro
i like the hat thank you yours too man
but bro gary you changed my [ __ ] life
man
like both like financially and like
mentally and like
i got a story that i think is gonna like
impact like everyone listening right now
so uh last june i started uh watching
your garage sale videos
okay i'm like [ __ ] i can do that [ __ ]
and at the time bro i only had fifty
dollars in my bank account
fifty dollars did you have did you have
debt
uh yeah cause i'm a college student too
so and i had a part-time job so i was
like still
doing [ __ ] but i was still doing that
you have 50 bucks
you see the video and you're like [ __ ]
that's not investing in facebook and
twitter that's not starting vaynermedia
that's not
that's something i can do sean i don't
want to get emotional
but the single reason i did that show
was for what you just said
in fact i'm so happy and i think the
world is so abundant that the only
[ __ ] thing i want
right now the only thing that's like the
true thing that drives me is to help
people
get happy and i came from dirt bro
same bro i wasn't giving [ __ ] yeah
like and i [ __ ] figured it out with
humility
and [ __ ] work ethic and education and
trash talk is education so keep going
you've got me
you got me on twitter go ahead you're
like [ __ ] i can do that i got 50 [ __ ]
dollars keep going
so i started going to garage sales like
thrift stores
now buy [ __ ] for a dollar and like i'd
even like sell for like two or three
dollars
on what craigslist facebook marketplace
because two three dollars on
but on ebay with feeds and shipping like
how did you make that work mainly ebay
um but i would like slowly like build it
up you were just learning even if you
made 50 cents you were learning you were
learning
even if you lost money where the
shipping cost you more than you thought
it was kind of okay because you were
like [ __ ] i'm learning yeah and plus
that like builds up your feedback and
like it helps
other stuff build up in ebay too and uh
and yeah i think just like anyone can do
that because i only had fifty dollars in
my bank account i was still working a
part-time job
and other people can do that too and
like the other like inspirational thing
is like
i'm also a college student and i was
working this past
school year i was working three times
three
part-time jobs plus a full-time college
student
and so like the whole thing like people
say oh i don't have time it's like
that proves it wrong like three part
time every throw everybody has time
people literally reply to me during
feeds like this i don't have time
yeah while watching me the [ __ ] are you
watching me if you don't have time
yeah you got to do i didn't watch
garyvee when i was a kid
like if i like i wouldn't watch [ __ ] i'd
be doing nonetheless
tell give me some highlight stories like
so now you're doing it what was your
first breakthrough what was the first
thing you bought
cheap and made some real money on you're
like yo this is [ __ ] different
uh i bought like this little einsteins
plane thing and had like all the figures
and everything
so it's like complete for five dollars
that fish at thrift store
and i sold it for a hundred on ebay i'm
like
[ __ ] dude since i'm just stupid like
that you know
and like you just keep learning and
learning and learning bro and then [ __ ]
gets better
and like bro this last month i just did
10k
in sales and i started with 50 in my
bank account bro
and like and the thing is anyone can do
this [ __ ] i know
the [ __ ] you think i'm talking about out
here yeah so i really want
bro i have a whole generation of guys
and girls watching me
who love gambling on sports when this is
happening
you need a high you need an extra high
to watch sports because you love it so
much
don't gamble on the panthers gamble on
their quarterback
if he sucks it goes down 20 if he's
right it goes up 500 percent
yeah instead of like 50 50 of losing all
of it
yeah you got to take that risk so like i
really want
people like to go follow my instagram
that i linked right here
go ahead i really i want to show people
that they can do this too and
because i know like there's that college
student out there or that mom out there
that's
struggling to put like food on the table
next week and
like you can do this [ __ ] like 15
minutes
so bro i'm looking at your content
you need to do more how-to because i'm
looking at it right now it's more
highlight reel
yeah and what you really need to do is
like if you want people to follow you
and i get the flex of like having more
followers
and you're at 2.99 now from 260 and i'm
sure i'll go to a thousand real quick
here
might but if you're good if you're going
to keep them
you got to give them value and like you
know this is great and it shows that
it's true
but you got to do what i do the reason
you know trash talk cost me money
drock's not free
my team i'm producing not free my time's
not free
but i'm showing them so you need to
really really really
show them like real and educate them
make video you know i see you getting
sports card flip
yeah how much how much did you pay for
this tray young that you sold for 338
uh like 200 dude the sports car thing's
been crazy huh
yeah and i i got two lucas back in
february bro
when you were talking when i was talking
about what you pay for it
250. now they're like almost a thousand
bro
well it's happening listen it's [ __ ]
happening out here and by the way
you know cards could go down but garage
sales yeah
they're never going anywhere
yeah so i please everyone
if you're watching like please go follow
it because it'll it'll make me want to
go even harder
and like really it'll help me i'll push
myself to go so
hear me hear me hear me real quick it
can't be about you
yeah true flip it i don't know listen
i'm listening i'm listening to you sean
you said hey follow me so i could be
more motivated to go harder
you're making it selfish you want to
grow be
selfless this is where everyone gets
caught this is why you won't
you may win the flip game but you will
not win the social media content game
because i'm listening to you i'm trying
to help you right now
this isn't about come follow me make my
self-esteem up at a thousand i can flex
this is about how do i bring them the
most value
this team with garyvee for this hour do
you know what kind of money i'm
could be making or doing things that i
need to be doing in this hour
this isn't about just watch my show when
i say share share share i'm not looking
for more [ __ ] followers
i'm looking to impact more people's
lives so that the sean
stumbles upon me and goes from 50 in his
bank account to 10k a [ __ ] month
yeah facts facts make it about that bro
you want to be like me make it about
them not about you
okay yeah i promise because right now
it's about you that's okay because
that's the old schwann that had 50 bucks
too and then he heard garyvee and he
[ __ ]
went now you're here together with me i
hope you hear me
make it about them yeah i really in the
end like i really just want to help
people
man no no you're still too early for me
to fully believe that
you still need much for you and that's
okay
that's fair it is fair because it's true
because i'm listening to you and i'm
watching you
but that's okay but make it about them
if you want to grow
okay yeah good man i wish you well
all right see ya talk to you
dustin yeah
fifty dollars in bank account to ten
thousand a month yeah that's
what you said that's crazy bro you could
make ten thousand a month on pokemon
cards if you get [ __ ] serious here
you're laughing i'm being dead [ __ ]
serious no i know but dude pokemon's
25th anniversary next year
yeah that's yeah do you understand how
hot they're gonna be
what you need to do is you need to buy
one for 300 sell it for 600 you don't
have the bankroll that i have
so you have to leave some money on the
table you have to buy a card for 300
sell in a month for 600 by doing
homework picking the right one it's
going to suck because that same card's
gonna be 2
000 in a year but you don't have the
depth of a bank account
so you need to just keep flipping so
that in six months you have thirty
thousand in profit
then you go ham then that thirty becomes
a hundred do you see where i'm going
the biggest problem for people right now
is they're like [ __ ] this is gonna keep
going up
but they don't have the bank
you don't have enough liquid yeah so you
need to buy
sell buy this is what i did as a kid now
i've worked my [ __ ] face off for 25
years to have the luxury of like
you know really going in and not having
to flip
and maximizing but as a kid i would buy
ken griffey for two bucks sell for three
bucks even though i know he's going to
five
you got to buy a squirtle flip it
and then buy something else that you
think is like there's so many things
that people haven't figured out like
there's pokemon charizard right now will
go up but there's
cards right now that people haven't
figured out or underpriced
you have to get deep into that world be
like wait a minute the base cards or the
trainer cards are actually underpriced
you see what i mean yeah that's how you
win not sitting with your collection or
looking at it
right
very good point thank you i mean i'm
always i'm still
doing a lot of like researching like
just watching youtube videos of
people like the experts doing it so much
free content on
there yeah you know yah shago's sports
cards are not popular in india
yet soccer cards will be josh pokemon
will be
maybe not american football basketball
maybe and maybe never
and that's okay buy them and ship them
to people in america i'm buying [ __ ]
from all over the place
you know what i haven't gotten into yet
that i'd like to is magic the gathering
big shout out to robbie turnick my best
friend as a child
he uh he uh he was right on magic
the first year i was like what is this
nerd [ __ ]
yeah i thought the same thing i love it
though real
all right let's keep going
gary what's going on brother what's
going on is that
you have a more professional mic than me
and everybody keeps yelling at me i
don't give a [ __ ]
that's what's going on sean well i have
it all set i had it all set up i figured
i'd use it
but thanks for uh thanks for your time
man i wanted to
give you a little background of my life
my brother and sister died when i was
15. about 11 years later
i'm so sorry to ask but like tragic
accident yeah about thanksgiving in 99
they died in a car accident yeah
i'm so sorry but yeah i mean you always
talk about
a man i mean the the pain learning from
your pain and your struggle
were you and how old were they i was 15
uh my sister was 21 and my brother was
18. oh my god
i'm so sorry my friend i appreciate it i
appreciate it man
but fast forward 11 years i had a
terrible divorce i have two kids
um i ended up getting prescribed pain
pills
hooked on heroin i was basically at the
point of being homeless
gotta got arrested for stealing out of
jail
from jail to short-term rehab long-term
rehab and then
i was actually still in my long-term
rehab out on passes
when i started a podcast centered around
mental health
mental health and addiction i was
started podcast what inspired you to do
that
uh every night uh room nine which is the
name of my company
um i was in room nine my long-term
treatment facility
and my roommate and i we were always
just talking about life you know how we
gonna
get better how we gonna fix our [ __ ] how
we gonna get our [ __ ] together
and so i was like dude we should start a
podcast and that's what we did
and so fast forward you know a little
bit even further now it's going on two
years i think i got over 90 episodes now
every monday
10 a.m and i've got a grant from new
york state
a small grant to start video production
and so i kind of
am moving into that and my main goal is
to really
get stories together of people who have
struggled with mental health and
addiction
and how they've struggled with it how
they overcame it and really kind of just
get a collection of those stories
together
i'm proud of you man i really really
admire you
i appreciate it yeah my uh my life all
my social life is gone now i'm just
trying to learn that
premiere pro after everything you know
getting into illustrator graphic design
and
really trying to put all the pieces
together but my
i guess i've been on this waiting list
to talk to you for three weeks now
and i'm not even the same person i was
three weeks ago just from what i've
learned and everything and
so my question like what am i going to
ask this dude
as uh is has changed but a bunch of
times i mean i know
yeah and i know you i mean you you talk
about patience man and
patience with time patience with
everything um your
relationship with failure i think that's
something i really want to push out to a
lot of people is
if you can open your eyes amongst pain
you can
you can change your entire life i mean
you can learn so much in that darkness
and i think that's something i really
want to push out but i guess my question
to you getting to it is
i really have fallen a lot in love with
brand strategy
and really like all right what is a
person's gut feeling when they think
about my company
yes and i just kind of i found i've been
able to take
my shittiness for my addiction my connie
and my
talking with people convincing them and
using that in
a positive powerful way sean they're
kissing cousins
my mom and dad literally every day like
every day i'm around them say my god if
you ended up being
bad instead of so good you would have
been the worst human of all time
like literally like they're like they
compare me to like some of the worst
people of all time
i actually sometimes i rare i don't i'm
not a praying man
but sometimes i literally look up
because i know i have such talent to
communicate
and i and and i just say thank you god
for not letting me be selfish and bad
because i would have [ __ ] this world
yeah when i hear you say that i get it
so much brother
i get it so by the way it's such a gift
and a power
that i feel like i feel this is a meta
moment i
i can't control the fact that i had to
like live
the garyvee life i have to give love
it's it's it's almost like i'm being
forced to by my chemicals
because i'm so capable of communicating
things
in in a way that almost every other
human doesn't have that ability
yeah you're exactly right all those
abilities you had on the bad
they're equally you just flip the coin
you were on tails bro
you were on tails and thank god
that you had the strength to flip it and
now you're on heads and it's gonna
[ __ ] work
i want to listen to your podcast i don't
want to listen to [ __ ]
that'd be great you should actually come
on sometime it's how about this it's
done
i'm on awesome whoever you've talked to
on this and i'll be on
in august
i love it the reason i'm doing it is
because i know that if you have me on
that you can then cold email everybody
on earth and say gary vaynerchuk was on
and you're gonna get a lot of yeses
i'm giving i don't have [ __ ] half
hour to be on your [ __ ] show
but i'm forced i'm forced out of my
gratitude to do it
i'm being dead [ __ ] serious
absolutely i know you're busy as [ __ ]
man
trust me i appreciate that greatly
enough to not give i appreciate it i
think i think that's
such an important message you give to so
many people that it is it's all about
giving and that's why i love branding as
opposed to advertising because branding
is about hey
give give give you know and let's pull
you in and that's why i've kind of
totally fallen in love did you read jab
jab jab right hook
i have not yet no dustin can we send
this guy jab jab jab right hook
all right that's on the way beautiful
awesome yeah man
well i appreciate your time dude have
you got into sports cards yet or pokemon
i have not gotten into any sports car
it's funny you talked about coins and no
kids uh like
my 13 year old loves collecting coins i
love it big shout out to the 13 year old
sorry i wasn't browsing
i didn't you know that's cool uh did you
grow up did you collect when you were a
kid any of that stuff
um i did actually yes show me sean
show me these are nothing but i just
found these in the basement if you
remember these uh
oh and to disappoint you i'm from
buffalo by the way
these pearl sets do you remember these
for of course i had
an ungodly amount of pro set hockey i
i had so many and then before that there
was
score i had so many score eric lindros
rookie cards you can't oh yeah
and by the way even though i hate the
bills i secretly have a lot of respect
for savers fans
that's been i like franchises that don't
win
that's buffalo and then have good good
fans i have a lot of respect for buffalo
secretly i can't like the bills
because they beat the [ __ ] out of the
jets in the 80s they you know you went
to four [ __ ] super bowls in a row
um but uh listen brother i love your
energy i'm so proud of you
keep fighting i know you know listen
unfortunately humans are undereducated
on addiction this is not something you
or this is something you battle daily
and i have a lot of respect for you and
i really am excited to come on
room9podcast.com
and uh and i'll see you in a little bit
and uh
and uh and i'm just glad you're here i'm
glad you're here in the macro you know
what i mean
absolutely i appreciate it i'm glad to
be here it was it was a switch that
flipped it
did we answer the question are we just
hanging out is there a question
yeah kind of i talked it was asking
about branding well
let me i mean here's branding it's about
what i just said to sean earlier
it's about them not you it's about
listening
you know everyone's so confused i
interrupt people this and that they're
like oh he's talking [ __ ] loudmouth
love to hear your [ __ ] own voice no i
don't
[ __ ] listen 24 hours a day and then
once in a while have a moment to talk
i'm [ __ ] listening 24 hours a day
sean i'm reading more comments more dms
more emails more texts
from my community than any [ __ ] on
earth i'm so busy that i'm not replying
like i used to but i haven't stopped
listening at all i'm [ __ ] hearing you
it's how i bring up my content it's how
it goes
branding and marketing is about the
customer not about your selfish wants
and needs that's why fortune 500
companies struggle that's why
vaynermedia's helped them so much
and that's why so many influencers suck
and that's why i'm helping them so much
and that's what you need to focus on
awesome
well i appreciate it brother and for
really really quick for anybody who out
there
um it just it was a switch for me it
just happened where i
just started loving myself and if you
don't take care of yourself and love
yourself and have confidence in yourself
and have confidence to fail i mean
that's the biggest thing
it's because everybody else sucks too
yep
we all stuck listen brother you went
through a super painful thing
i don't know what kind of person you
were at 15 if that was inevitable that
you were going to go down
a tough path because of the chemicals
because of the parenting
but [ __ ] bro to go through that kind of
tragedy that's a shock
no it is yeah you know i didn't even
realize how much it [ __ ] me up until
probably a decade later
of course because you know whatever you
you know again i'm running out of time i
to run to a client but
maybe you were trying to be strong for
your appearance i don't know your
circumstance but
it's the subconscious that takes over
yep
absolutely all right care well i'll let
you get going brother i uh
i appreciate your time man you're the
best matt
in the comments big shout out to you way
to fight through that meth
addiction thank you sean i love
everybody i hope everybody's super well
um
i love you see you tomorrow or am i
tomorrow dustin
yep oh all right
i want to go friday though just tomorrow
see you tomorrow everybody
please please please let's get a [ __ ]
load of people watching this [ __ ]
we're helping out here see ya